Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Ben the Exorcist
I'm assuming that I'm Ben
and I see something popping out from behind the couch there.
If you look riiiigghtt-
Oh hi!
Hello do I need to exorcise you?
Difficult: Story lover, watch your back, may god help you
I'm just gonna do watch your back,
because you guys should be watching your back, its already in your house
its already standing right behind you but don't turn around 'cause that'll really piss it off
I oh Hello!.. This is Ben
"THE EXORCIST"
The call was from the Witherspoon family I can sense the terror that they have been though in the moment I heard Jerry's voice.
Ah yes Jerry my old pal from war days.
Ben the Exorcist? Please, Help us!
Then he told me the terryfying story that happend in their new house.
Ohh
It all started on Halloween when his daughter with her friends decided to perform spiritual ritaual
Of course why not
They've awaken dark spirits.
Since that day life of the Witherspoon
family became a nightmare
Every time they ordered burgers they dissapeared
in strange circumstances.
"MY BURGERS!"
Oh...
All healthy organic gluten free food ends up in the trash bin
Noo! *laughing* my expensive organic
Food!..
Son became sick all the time and the doctors
coudn't cure him
Achoo..!! *Giggly markimoo*
Daughter coudn't sleep because of some strange noise
that bother her every night.
Not this terrible song again I'll be deaf soon
ok well sleep somewhere else
The strangest was the stinky smoke that comes from nowhere
Firefighter that come to the house and accused family
of doing stupid jokes and made them pay an expensive bill
Ohh life is just hell everyone's gonna die or something
"Why nobody believes us?"
I was their only hope
Ah.
You need to leave the house immediately!
I'm on my way!
I can't believe they didn't think of this before leaving the- oh hi
Oh boy Ben's on the case here, BEN'S! GONNA FIND OUT, are there any ghosts over here?
Huh!..
I got my cross here
*Intense Breathing*
How many more can there possibly be?
Press 2 to use it
Select aspragilim?
HIYA
I don't know what that did but I did something about it
can I go in here ohh just like that
HAYAHA..
alright so what is this my detector?
ohh this spo-spo-spot is particularly haunted
alrighty
sarsparilla
avocados
something like that
think I did good I think I did good there
so I gotta detect me some
Haunted Locals..
Ehh..
Hello?
Is the backyard haunted?
I can't see Jack-Doodly I donno know if my thing is spinning
is there anybody here?
ahh (first scare of the video)
What the fuck was that? Ohh.. I got hit with a rake
Ahhhhhhh
Rake is back again
can I get this, this sarsparilla?
what do you see on the inkblot test
Ok
splooshy
spladooshy
ok maybe not,
Hello?
I'm here to uh help?
Ohh..
Oh...
Wow!..
Wow! its an actual working mirror?
No! way in hell is this even possible.
There's been game's I'm playing Prey right now and even
they don't even have working mirrors.
Oh..
These are blank.
Ah.. ok I guess it all was clever ruse
*Drops*
Alrighty then
This is obviously not haunted here.
Ah.. I didn't get this spot
Hang on
Hang ON!
HaNG ON!
HANG ON!!!
WOAHH!!
Wait..
Nope
WOAHHH!!
Here we go
Gahh..
I don't know what those words mean but I hope its doin the demons away.
I'am just gonna keep Splish-Splashin down until I get to where I get to where I need to go.
What happens if I Splish-Splash the fire
Is this gonna to anything?
HAYA!..
HAYAAaa!..
I can't put it out
I've got an unlimited supply of holy water apparently
Which is good I-I-I think?
Oh Hello
"HAYA!"
"HaYAa!.."
"HAyA"
"HAYA!"
"HaYAa!.."
I think that did it?
Oh HI!..
Okey well thats a good poster to have [SARCASM]
Just one of the kids rooms or something?
Hello?
Is this one Haunted?
Little bit of spinning action but not alot!...
maybe in the co - oh hi barbarian gentleman the flower curse
Ahh..
Lovely
Okey then
Somewhere near by?
Oh
This is IT!
AHhh..
HeYAAah...
Amen indeed Oh!..
Ahh?...
Easy job look around I don't know what that mean by easy job?
Hello?
HEllOo?!...
I've got splooshing water you don't want non a this.
ERr..
I can't see anythin
Ooh.. Ominous music
Is someone gonna steal my burgers or someone actually spook me here?
Hmmm..? Oh Hi!
Ouh..
Hi!...
Hello!..
I'll go up in the attic in just a bit I need to investigate whatever this means?
Are you gonna spook me?
AHh.. Okey..
HAaaYyy...
Hi!..
Jerry?
Je-JErry!..
Hey come ON!..
NOW!..
Oh you just met your first enemy
uh HAAA!
this seems a lot less like a ghost and more like
uh
HO!
apparently that worked
OK
Uh Oh!
AHHHH!
Well the door wasn't even open so I don't know how that worked
HEY HEY HEEY!!!!
OH GOD OH GOD!!!
hello
hi
no no noooo
no no no no no no no
no no no no
uhh almost gotcha
yeah (x4) you got nothin on me
what do you mean exorcism doesn't work he just got exorcised
he got exorcised into a puddle of goop
wha-holy water I thought I had enough holy water
Holy water? I thought I had enough holy water.
"You are not prepared: Info about ghosts. Perfume bottle."
I don't understand how that helped me!
But, ok. Alright, I'm gonna guess that I'm o-
Oh it is.... it's dark up here...
It's a whole lotta dark.
Teh darkness, it's all around me.
Euh
Hi then, ok..
Alright then!
Ben the exorcist is- AHEYYYY
*Mouse squeaking*
FUCKING HI
......Okay......
Well then!
That mouse met its bitter end and I did not facilitate that in any way.
Hello, hi.
Ah, yes, good.
So.. how in the heck- oop
-do I get to.. what I needed?
OHHHHH I can turn lights back on!
OHHHH I didn't know that was a thing!
ahhh
So that's gonna help me immensely.
AHHH
IT'S BRIGHT!
Where's the dead rat?
Cause that rat is dead for sure- oh
Yeah, I thought you knew Jerry.
You knew him on a first name basis! Mr. Witherspoon, I'm pretty sure you're familiar with Jerry.
Ok, yeah that's a good-
Oh, oh is that? Oh, Ok!  Alright then!
Oh It's just, you know, Ben here! Gonna forsake all of my training!
All of my religious beliefs in order to dispel this ONE ghost.
This demon infesting this house.
Alright, nice tissues behind the computer there.
Alright, what do we have here?
OHHH my GOD.
OHH the TWO HUNDRED YEAR orgasm!
OHHHHH HUHU YEHAHA
Ok, anyway, sorry about that.
Looks like the son here had some.. other interests.
AYYHH
Fucking what are you doin?
Ohohohohoho
uh ohoHOHO
Who's in there?!
Hi- WHOA- hi- whoa I didn't expect you to actually be a thing!
ahh
What?
Why you- game OVER?
WHAT??
WHAT DO YOU MEAN "GAME OVER?"
What did I do??
What did I do wrong?
What'd I do wrong? What did you do to me? What did I do to me?
What did we all do to each other?
What happened to us? What happened to us, guys?
Stooop, don't be like that...
Someone really li-
Hi. What are you doing in there?
You gonna be something here, huh?!
Whoaaa, hey. Hey again.
yeeee
I- eh-  I- I don't know what to do about this
Uh huh. Yeah, that's right!
Geeet out of here!
You're not a-welcome here.
Yeah, sure.
*Mark reading letter*
How long have they been dealing with this CUUURSSSEE?
Should I- should I keep this?
uh
Whaaat?
Who is SHE?
You mean mum and dad or- who you talking about?
I was talking about the son.
Who's got all his jacking books under his pillow.
Oh, hi.
Fucking hi, fucking hi- NOOOO!!
ANYTHING BUT THAT!
Ohhh NO.
Hi puppers, is that Chica? That looks like Chica.
Alrighty then.
Anything?
huh.. OHOHOHO
The two hundred year orgasm again!
Oh, what's this?
This does not help me..
but.. maybe this would?
No.
This?
This ghost what-  HEEYYY
Ok, or maybe I could just get out of this house and we could
burn it to the ground. Because that's also an option.
We could do that.
We could definitly do that.
If anybody  could do that, then I think it's we that we should do that.
So HOW am I supposed to get down to the basement ALL BY MY LONESOME?
I don't have a god-damn flashlight and I don't even remember seeing the basement in the first place.
How do I get to the basement?!
Is there, like, a cellar door in the backyard?
OHHH
AHHHH
GOOOOOOD
I'll just go down here then...
Oh it's dark... oh it's dark
Oh, it's DARK.
OHHHH, DARK IS WHAT IT IS!
I CAN'T SEE SHIT.
*mumbling* Oop, I see something here.
Hello?
And.. almost there, F?
I don't know- AHEY
I lost it- oh, there it is.
*clap*
I don't know what this is doin.
I don't know what this is doing.
Did I do it? I don't think I did it.
NOPE
WWHOOOO, WWWHHOO'S UP THERE HUH??
I need a flashlight- oh.. hi.
Who?
WHOOOS UP THERE?
Something weird is going on and I don't know what it is.
Hello? HEY-
Fucking-
Oh, hi! I know what that sound was.
It was that lady crawlin'.
HI
uh oh
uh oh uh oh uh oh uh oh
uh oh uh oh uh oh
uh oh uh oh
UH OH
What the fuck is that?
Ok, BYE. Where are you going?
Man, she ZOOMED right up those stairs.
Wha- WHAT IS THAT?
WHAT IS COMING FROM HERE?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh, hi. Hello you.
Ok. Where is she though?
uh oh
Oh, there you are-
NANANANA NO NO NO NO NO
NANANANANA
NANANANA
NANANANANANA- NAAAAAAAAANANA
WHOAHOHO
AHHHHHHAHA
UH OH UH OH
I'm doomed
Oh, I've been goobergabbed.
Alright, I'm gonna give this another try. This is getting, it's getting, a little bit janky here but
we're getting there.
I don't know what I did, am I at the power off stage yet?
Ohhhh, I'm up HERE NOOOOOWW
Ah, ya gotta be shittin my donker.
Aha! I got a perfume bottle that I need to fill with water for some reason.
Okay... HOLY water..
Alright, I need more items connected to the ghost.
I don't know where to find those but I'm gonna find em' as best I can-
A FLASHLIGHT!
Ohhhhhh
It's also an ultra-violet flashlight- which is a weird thing to have in a normal family household.
Can I just make it with that paint then? Alright, I think I'm onto something here.
I think I'm onto something.
So now that I got this flashlight, once the power goes out I'll be able to go down into the basement
and not die a horrible, painful death...
Alrighty then.
Off we go, scadadally-wadally.
"ME" "HI" "LAZY" "VT" "KOX" "FUN"
Are they?
Are they kox fun?? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Its that what it is?
Ah
Ok..
HEYY
Alright, prooobably should.
I'll just see about that.
And now that I got a flashlight it will go much easier for me.
Ok, here we go! SCADADALLY-DOO
Who's down here?
OHHHH
There was a whole other room over here that I never saw because I couldn't see it, because it was DORK.
Hello?
ah
NAIL KILLS?
NAIL KILLS??
LIKE, THESE NAILS?!
Like just nail vanity or something?
I dunno what you're talking about
Oohhh, hello
Ahhh
Ker-chunkles???
I think that did SOMETHING?
It looks like it did something, woah
*ominous music*
Oh no!
Ohh, oh hohoho
Are... Are you trying to...
Are y-you trying to sell me NicoBoost?
Miss fire-lady-guy/dude I don't know
Should I try to...
Y'know, like, exorcise you or something?
Hello?
Hii... Okay, goodbye then
I, I guess goodbye
*nervous laugh*
Yeah okay, yeah let's go with that one, that's a good idea
Definitely gonna get some clues from that radio
OHHHH but the power works, I think
Which is awfully good and nail also still kills but, okay
Going upstairs now!
Skedadalee-dee, skedadalee-doo
I'm gonna keep that open just in case I need to run
Where did you deduce that? From this?
From this action?
Oh, did someone fall down the stairs? Is that what happens
Is it all the rakes and the GOOP LYING AROUND??
Uhhhh yes, I'm gonna go with yes
WOAH hi
Ughhh
Okay, is this the fire department smell that everyone was talking about?
Is that a cloud of death?
Please tell me that's not a cloud of death
I don't know what I can do about that cloud
That sure is a stink cloud alright if I ever seen one
So uh, what am I supposed to do about the stink cloud
that's moving through this house?
Well I guess absolutely nothing then
I'll just let it carry on it's life
*spoopy noise* HIIiii
*noise repeats* fucking god...
Hi... *spoop*
You doin' something there?
Woah
Okay
And now we've got that
Uh oh
Well anyway
Now that we've got that
I THOUGHT
The CRAWLY lady was gonna come out after me again
But there's a SAFE there
And I don't know a code
I don't have any idea how to get a code
Do I have an inventory of some sort?
Could I, pop a radio open, plop there a second *radio plays*
Did you overdose from uhh...
Nicotine?
Last smoke: earring?
I don't know what that meeaaans
I don't understaaaand you
Okay good
Alright then
Wait
I need this don't I?
EMPTY
I could use a drink right about now
That's for damn sure
Ben the Exorcist needs a goddamn drink
Sorry
*sniffs* sorry...
*music intensifies*
Ohhh, hello
Why did you reject me?
*BANG*
HII, I DON'T KNOW!
OHH, hi!
Hello!
Hi! (Hi Mark~)
Okay!
Hi!
And also hello!
*MUSIC INTENSIFIES*
OKAY!
Gonna try and exorcise you!
Ohhh...
*nervous chuckles*
The hell was that?
Just, ahhhhh
I'm gonna get'cha NEXT TIIIIIIME
But not today
So...
Is that the ghost of someone that, like
Burnt to death around here or something?
Ohh
What is that?